citizens of the reject Nation it is time for
The Dark Knight to return again this is The
Dark Knight Returns part two this is our first
sequel or or continuation this is our first part
too so please leave a comment letting us know
which of the DC any movies you like most which
of the universes you enjoy most is Multiverse
weekend so which of the multiverses are you
enjoying the most I'm got a lot of love for this
Frank Miller where I'm not gonna lie and remember
to hit that like so I know that you are liking
these very very things now today as we dive in
there's a very special thing about to happen we've
got a brand new shirt I haven't seen it yet so in
real time I'm gonna experience this shirt John
are you ready I am ready I don't know if you're
ready Greg showed me this and I was like oh snap
that's an armor store so three two one check it
out koi look at this oh shirt yes the bat verse
shirt you know I gotta say I think that was my
favorite Batman oh you heard at least two out of
three I might have to put a bail in there okay but
that's fair two out of three favorite Batman right
there not bad and you gotta have the OG for the
shirt because the verse the tag that's live as
of right now in the shopzeroedition.com store go
check that out conceived of by Greg and the shop
Zero edition team I I'm probably gonna acquire
one of those but before we do remember if you want
to watch the entirety of this journey non-edited
our full experience every waking moment but come
on patreon get over there for the front to back
start to finish complete journey and now it's
time for Frank Millers The Dark Knight Returns
several Splinter groups that formed from
the remnants of the mutant gang after
their leader was defeated by the Batman
my man seventh time how are the sons of
Batman his responsibility he didn't create
them they exist because Batman broke up the
larger gang why we didn't want these costumed
Heroes I'm so curious what this taste kind
of sound like yeah who's the voice I see
my favorite patient is up and about just
super to see how well you're doing for years it
seemed like you didn't have a reason to go on
I get invited on the talk show circuit now
and then must be wonderful to get to tell
your side of things I know the world
has every reason to hate me of course
don't make me feel bad for him crying
clowns only use for violence oh don't
you do it in one of the shows oh
please no one wants to hear from
me I'll make some calls right now
could you introduce me as Joker
sure Robert De Niro's there yeah make sure
Murray's there you know I like to keep you
out of domestic affairs with all the Ruckus
you stir up yes sir President Reagan now I'm
not asking you to put him down not yet anyway ride
him around the yard a few times if you have to you
know what I'm asking oh what oh damn you know
how to get in touch with him don't you son oh
geez Reagan riding around a few times
Donna Justice boy you even old enough to drink
drink we slice our dices we prove it you keep
slicing Dice and when you're holding guns because
it's got a weird thing with the slicing and Dyson
yeah you're not too bright are you
whoa the most Frank Miller designs
oh man lady Spud nine Rob whoa I
need the points whoa yes let's go
who is this so brutal no no you
got this ugh look at all Nazi nips
who's kicking over this character
design and look how it's translated
into animation is so like Reagan looks
like a mix of Frank Miller and Reagan and
then she is well the most Frank Miller
yeah hey [__] this fight is fantastic
whoa pull that trigger and I'll be back for you
oh
Bruno's heading your way leader
into the alley do not let her see
you why I like that order and you're
fired yes oh do not let her see you
maybe not the celebration damn it now you're
fired come on and he meant it of course maybe
he just met your five years she's in the alley
so she did her job if you're lucky Bruno you'll
end up in jail tonight first you're going to tell
me what Joker has planned for his TV appearance
an incredible punch line I assure you
the speed of this hack oh I would love
it if he just continued forever Batman
is the hag yeah it's Baba Yaga well then
she just like went down to shoot it like
into that hole she made with grenades oh
[Music] brought a kid with him
excellent timing oh no no the blind guy
whoa
cool probably would have been
easier to grab him and move him
sure but you know but you want to make
that big impression yeah that entrance
so you have like a whole makeup
designed for this Alfred doesn't
and like the seats there and applique
yeah Alfred went to cinema makeup School
this
oh we have to talk my place in the morning until
then stay out of my way all right like there's
some respect get that respect it's good just
appointed a new police commissioner and I'm not
about to interfere the job will officially change
hands from outgoing Commissioner James Gordon
to incoming Ellen yendel oh yeah neither has
commented yet on Ms jindal's plans did she come
around to the Batman they do a really good job
pacing it as a part one and part two like it feels
connected but you can watch them separate yeah
and it has that like rewarding if you did watch
part one right now you're back yeah a man returned
to the public eye who refuses to do nothing while
chaos runs rampant now it's commissioner yandel's
turn to face this man she may make him her enemy I
wish her well interesting speech suggestion speech
about Batman my species it's all about Batman
but this office will no longer tolerate the
actions of a criminal immediately my speech is
about Batman yes [Music] yes on the charges of
breaking and entering yes salt and battery and
creating a public menace I hereby issue a warrant
for the Batman's arrest he has done those things
fight the good fight Yandel
amazing most American you have to go back
into retirement you're upsetting too many
people why do you always look at
him Majestic oh man you act like
a criminal we are criminals Clark we always
have been and these are our symbolism animals
mine has teeth you got an eagle either shut it
down or one of these days someone with authority
is going to tell me to come stop you when that
happens May the best man win spoken like a true
Batman that one scene sets up things so much
better than a lot of the movies tried to yeah
even with the Americana that's so Frank Miller
too now those Soviets would like to see us turn
our tails and run but we've got to protect our
interest I mean stand up the freedom Freudian slip
we've got God on our side or the next best thing
anyway lots of advanced weaponry and an alien
and people still love Reagan
and this is not inaccurate
whoa
whoa plant that flag run again with it like the
moon landing hmm oh I also made you these special
filters wear them tonight and or your nose uh I
could kiss you [Music] who is that voice it's so
disconcerting it's so like got a texture to it
yeah it's like so silky in a disconcerting way
animated movies are so good at making toy man so
uncomfortable yeah he'd be a good opening villain
in one of the Matt Reeves movies oh that'd be
fun yeah I'm not waiting to find out what the
Joker is up to and you can bet Batman isn't either
neither of them is leaving here a free man Blade
Runner Vibes accelerate Bobby Mary Uncle Joker's
counting on you oh go make them proud oh that is
toy man who is that it's uncomfortable stay in
the copter and do not touch any of the controls
if there's any trouble just say boosters you
don't need to understand a thing that's Siri yeah
[Music]
he can fly so cool to have
it coming out of nowhere whoa
POV mow down and the spotlight
Batman you are under arrest
oh damn that I felt that I always
take this moment to say a little
affirmation to myself so many forces so
few Smiles hey now no need to be nervous
Zappa's not a good psychiatrist you're not
very Observer man has lost his mind that
is about to murder he looks very comfortable
and confident do the monologue do a tight five
whoa Jesus taking this shot yourself
saw some blood I think yeah do you bleed
whoa do something
drone babies I'm told you've killed about
600 people that's right Conan stop right
there wow coming up to date with Tony
man and I won't have him being harassed
I want people to get me that's why I'm gonna kill
everyone in this room I think that's a little more
insight than we had in mind he's just trying
to ease the tension funny way to go about it
and I would know would your guests get to keep
these sure you do whatever you want
with it we got a closet full of them
oh don't kill Conan zap is already gone
[Applause]
that's a nightmare [Music] [Applause]
ah Joker toxin
all the bloody fingers oh they're like
rotting in place It's the funniest your
show's ever bit David in the crib the most he's
enjoyed it oh really close Ace the cloak oh
come on bats whoa yeah
backseat Batman I like that she just knows
how to fly it it's over Joker's gone Lots
scores very Batman but new I like it
it's like a mix of different gears toward
peel she changed it to swag peel
let's do this wow
damn soups taking on all the
KGB at one time that hair of
Justice look at that pompadour man
that flowing curl [Music] oh yeah
so terrifying a Superman was real Joker is
hell gas audience Kyle escorts Batman who Tangled
with police at the scene this is Selena you never
should have come back Bruce you don't know
how much the world has changed Selena oh no
hey put your lipstick back on he
does it presentationally yeah you
know where you are I need your
help it's very important oh no
my help I made myself pretty for you you should
say thank you thank you dang I have a little
errand for one of your girls I think her name's
Elsie she has a date with a congressman tonight
oh yeah [Music] there's something I need
you to do conquerors men will you do it yes
howdy Congressman Hector Alejandro noches has
climbed out into a 40th story ledge and is
demanding a full nuclear strike against Corto
Maltese look at me Hector what is happening
in that man we have to strike first we're
the most powerful country in the world sir
please oh no yeah he caught the flag that's
what's important yeah it represents something
o'holleran sixth Precinct Lieutenant
this wasn't a suicide the girl upstairs
courts shut it down and bring her in
oh Lieutenant o'holleran man I heard
there was was something wrong stop that
oh my god oh let's double the Batman oh of course
duh this is yeah God I love the disguises in this
no no that's messed up in a Wonder Woman get up
cotton candy Fairgrounds thousands will be there
half my friends will be there bring the wing
in close don't take the girl don't worry well
oh man
jeez Ugg oh
there it is great nice
free I don't mind I trusted it was obviously
good for you free everything can go wrong
God these two don't like them do you know why
all these people are so upset that bad man up
there Bobby you know what to do get him
mother show them your propane accessories
oh that boy was all propane accessories
ah boy ain't right boy ain't right
in the eye don't leave in such a
rush whoa damn deck that kids mom
I love how the anime has like wild motion with the
gun too yeah and then all the reflections of Chaos
let the boy go Joker you know fall for that joker
oh that's bad you should get that
look now when you have a chance
yeah that's a good reaction in skull
cars no less yeah come on [Music]
yeah yes come out come out yes that's why
I don't Skip Leg Day nope even after all
those hops oh my God oh my God what a way to
go ah yes that ride is down for maintenance
[Music]
damn it Andy got extra clips it's
a big old body count in this one
thank you and it is like very unsettling to
see Joker just get away running people down
yeah like especially nowadays like yeah it's
just a guy with a gun can do this and this is
the tunnel of gloves that's where
they belong but kill them yeah no more
stop it already all the people I've murdered I
never kept count I did I know
and I love you for it just
it's finally here isn't it the moment we
both dreamed about oh mama where we kill
each other oh don't tell me you're
gonna fall asleep before we finish
seems like you have an age today it's all
preserved like Keith Richards
we can still end on a high note
oh
go ahead say this has never happened
to you before I win I made you lose
control and they'll kill you for it oh you in hell
hahaha that whoa is among the hardest things I've
ever seen just completed his own neck snap
oh with no hands this is your force a will
whoa
wow not giving a a fudge
yep not to move
that's a very Frank Miller aside
beautiful
cool nice
I never killed at least a couple cops in that oh
wait kill the Joker killed
a half a squadron a police
cops and Gotham sure like Stormtroopers
neutral Target neutral Target uh
come on kid
come on
you do feel the weight of Destruction in this
just a very violent in Frank Miller's world
yes and just like dropping blood everywhere yeah
like it's all yeah you're like weighted [Music]
foreign [Music]
wow that's gotta be painful yeah I bet
lasso around the bleeding wounds yeah
yeah maybe it'll uh Holden it shut though
cauterize kill Liv he's far too stubborn to die
a casual Tuesday for Alfred the
Batman has revealed himself to be an
Advanced the governor to put them City's
disposal to hunt down this dangerous fugitive wow
did I did attack police he and I don't talk
anymore I know everything I need to know
damn it's probably in the Next Room
groceries now want to eat tonight I'm going oh
you go back to the Alan Moore comic book store
for the best office yeah that's
why Jim agrees to get the groceries
it's a man of taste the good news is that
our brave American troops were victorious
in Corto Maltese bad news is looks like
those Russians are some mighty sore
losers what Reagan oh my God launch the
nuke and it gets out of the planet jeez
[Music]
it's okay Superman will take care of it [Music]
come on you got the soups
ah whoa getting reports that the
missile has changed course and
will now detonate over and cool that was
really well paced yeah that got me [Music]
that's not good for Gotham no
[Music]
oh Jeeps
A Thousand Suns wow
it looks so emaciated now oh
God right in on the symbol of Hope yeah jeez
[Music]
uh that's not good we are not in Kansas anymore
did he re-inflate just there you see Frank
Miller thinks sunflowers are little Sons
same radiation on the emergency
generator hasn't kicked in yeah
what's up with that Aces my Cheapo watch stop too
an electromagnetic pulse in all likelihood
from a nuclear explosion you don't know that
oh yes you do oh dear Soviets detonated a cold
bringer not meant to kill us just [__] us ever
ride a horse before yes I've never seen a horse
before yes let's go so sweet that horse love it
yeah you really gotta figure
out the whole hip language yeah
tailbone all day we will take charge we will kill
anyone anyone away no listen to me I'm Batman I
am going to maintain order in Gotham City you
are going to help me these are loud and clumsy
these are the weapons of cowards yes where's that
image tonight we are the law tonight I am the law
looters are gonna strip us dry we
need more cops on the street one
at a time commissioner we got
a problem cops by candlelight
oh no utter chaos Gotham of blackout
would be so terrifying oh well
they've been waiting you go extinguisher lady ow
whoa [Music] this is so freaking cool that
horse I love it more bad horse always bowling
wow nice touch with the glasses
that's true so if any of you want bruise
over your heads tomorrow start helping
yeah build don't destroy
it's okay kid it's gonna make you big and strong
your community spirit
some of you will even argue that you can't
work together that's mine that's fine stay
tied up what is this the Gestapo he lumps
us together with criminals shut up man
ought to be that voice actor shut up shut
up man I'm sure you're all eager to help
[Music]
nice come on man I'm suing good luck with that
freaking guy oh what are we gonna do nothing
he's too big there you go you finally figured
it out all you gotta see is him inspiring
a little social change that's what it is
right now no
[Music] is this honey in there [Music]
is Mama Gordon inside oh Backdraft
oh oh thank God I'm glad she had to
go to the store too the impact on the
weather patterns is expected to last
much longer it's high noon in Gotham
City and yet there's no sun and
it's the coldest day of the year
nice lightning bolt earring though only Gotham
has maintained order being led by the Batman
oh boy the only safe place is Gotham so long as
you're up to handling our other little problem
now he'll never let me bring him in alive you do
what you do sure oh wow who are you serving there
Clark those Spangles you draw too much attention
to yourself you play it mysterious you have to
kill what is it you want Oliver the Schoolboy I
always knew it would come down to the two of you
someday the world's not big enough for the both of
you yeah just come here for old time's sake got a
one-armed boner lately it's been cold a lot yeah
same same out here I always love that character
design choice of like take she's been taking
his arm and like yeah you [__] Green Arrow
where
um
oh no [Music] it's even close
to fully recovered neither is he
wowie he doesn't need a walking hospital
bed to keep his insides together
wow it does fall within my duties
gotta get my my calcium some ibuprofen's a
little sore evacuate at the downtown slum
known as Crime Alley no explanation has been
given and news coverage has been flatly yes
I love the way they made the tail look at
the best yeah like a beast bat big ears on
the front yeah you'll still be weak between
the consolidual sunlight just how weak we'll
see when he finds my first surprise but did you
do like a gym sesh before this gotta get that
pump on train like Affleck I'm trying to get the
plan here I mean you gonna die tonight or what
I figure I will or what I'm going with or
what do not engaged just monitor his position
[Music]
uh boy [Music] whoa oh my god wow
it's like a brick foreign
damn
[Music]
careful oh God careful kid isn't this a
school night young lady Clark ah what's
up shoot let slingshot go we don't have
to do this I'm sure we do whoa [Laughter]
you know what my orders are your orders woof
oh jeez whoa
I like how limited movement it is it's all
just like attacking with environment like
he's not able to be fast so he's just finding
every tool at his immediate disposal yeah
it's okay buddy no no
foreign
what kind of authority is that oh boy
ah doesn't matter matters their world
and they won't stand for you anymore
if it isn't me it'll just be someone else
who do they send after you yeah seriously
[Music]
all right
slingshot him yes I'm so hoping for it
wow nice whoa
yeah it's on you guys
I'm getting out of here oh
you're a quick study kiddo
I love the snowfall too
yeah a little depth of field
the Superman Christopher Reed
poster in the background ah
it was the coolest day of that kid's life
[Music]
that's awesome
came in like a wrecking ball
[Music]
oh my this fight is so cool animated yes
oh
oh wow Bruce this is idiotic
I'll get the Callum for the soldiers arrive
foreign
[Laughter]
anything good on yes [Music]
oh come on Oliver Redemption
is he gonna knock it with his teeth or something
oh
what's that acid burns Superman
so cool lovely looks like an
old pirate yeah oh no damn you
whoa
what are you doing do you want me to kill
you oh you're not going to kill me [Music]
it wasn't easy to make Clark it took years
and cost a fortune exactly I had both
oh yeah
the freaking silver away
heart
no
we got him they got nowhere
to go uh we'll see about that
[Music]
I love you Clark I wanted to remind you
to stay out of my way in all the years to
come in your most private moments I want
you to remember the one man who beat you
and then nature beat him
damn
oh yeah
it's like his life force is tied to the
house yeah to the manor don't touch him
the proceedings are underway
today for Bruce Wayne [Music]
ladies such a good photo they still LED with
that photo though as the Batman died with him
as Wayne Manor burned to the ground every penny
of Wayne's wealth have also disappeared [Music]
oh [Music] you've got some
Nerf showing up here I know
who killed him damn you aha it's
no use let's go were you a friend
I think so I honestly couldn't say
sounds about right that's a good moment
oh kiddo hey
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes so much yes yes oh so good so freaking
good oh there's a fresh spring under here I
want our water supply set up in one hour
we ain't got forever people sure we do
whoo [Music] so cool you're going to be my Army
operating in the shadows keeping Gotham safe
all right the Schoolboy found you out it's all
right I think the message got through you leave
us alone I spent 10 years looking for a good
death this will be a good life sure and then
later on you can mentor a protege perhaps Terry
McGinnis maybe that's a it's an idea [Music]
yeah bat OS
[Music]
sweet that was cool tray legitimate
that was cool tray legitimate Jay Oliva
man they really did it yeah they really made
Frank Miller like sing and animation absolutely
so good as Batman yeah I feel like we've heard
Peter Weller like another one of them somewhere
Michael Emerson was Joker yeah then I forgot
which is nice yeah absolutely and he's got
such a yeah just such like an eerie softness
to his voice just an uncomfortable like Vibe
at all times yeah absolutely so soft-spoken
but powerful uh-huh and I like that like I
don't know because there are so many iconic wild
jokes on the Joker I do appreciate that and it
feels appropriate for like a Frank Miller joint
that it should be like a little different Frank
Miller's definitely got that like he's suited
up he's he's got like the bravado like he he
reads more confident than crazy yeah so like the
using the Michael Emerson take definitely worked
for me yeah it was definitely a different joke
I didn't feel like the Joker it felt like Frank
Miller's Joker sure which I think it needed to
yeah and all Michael Jackson's back yay Yuri
um man that was intense absolutely I friend and
two like so much of you know I I had forgotten so
much of the you know main points of the story I'd
forgotten about those two demon kid drone things
all together yeah yeah at all and and everything
with Superman and all that stuff and it's funny
I mean obviously that has inspired many a thing
but uh I thought the way too that that whole thing
went down like it's one of those things where
you're like oh yeah we still have to resolve that
like yeah everything with the joker and everything
that has mounted up until this point all the chaos
of Batman returning but we also have to deal with
like the government and and them wanting to track
down Batman and put an end to it and taking
Batman out of the equation yeah like completely
and I I really I that might be my favorite of the
adaptations of the Batman Superman fight that was
a really really cool way to tell that it felt more
brutal it felt more realistic there's something to
the suspension of disbelief of like you have to
really suspend disbelief to think that Superman
could fight Batman yeah Batman could like keep up
yeah but in animation with the you know the nuke
with the sun with the like there's a hundred
big variables that allowed for it yeah well
I think you know you you hear the Prospect and
you're like oh they're gonna have a fist fight
and they're like and you're like nah the only
way this fight will work is if Batman brings a
ton of other Provisions because Superman doesn't
need all that stuff so right and Superman has to
be weakened by the planet yeah exactly so it's
like okay we gotta launch a bunch of missiles at
him and then we gotta electrocute him and then
we got a Kryptonite him and then yeah it's and
we can only get that close because he's that
slow because he's been drifting through space
after getting nuked in the face like it has to be
that yeah and that's what I don't feel like other
adaptations I've done accurately sure doesn't ever
feel like the stakes have gotten to the point of
anything close to equal yeah it's like I don't
believe a wholesale that just yeah mechanized
suit is gonna be the key It's gotta be more than
just like to me it was like okay the suit is like
the the cautionary it's the armor it's the the
safest Safeguard but it's not the weapon but
even like Iron Man couldn't find Superman like
even Batman in an iron suit like if you're making
itself ripped that apart if he was at Power yeah
and that's whatever translated for me it was like
yeah I'm still just a guy in a suit and that's
Superman yeah 100 and so here I thought yeah they
managed to bring it all onto a playing field and
two they had like the personal like you know you
don't spend a lot of time with their relationship
obviously like most of their history is off screen
here yeah and based on your knowledge of you know
the Justice League and other things from from
various other comics and stuff and so yeah to have
them on this wavelength where they're convincing
each other like they're trying to convince each
other like colleagues would yeah you know and and
and people who do you know straddle that line of
like are we kind of friends like you know we're in
a unique position that only we can identify with
so yeah it's like I love the way they realize the
physical Stakes but also the emotional aspects
of that and and even having it come down to you
know Batman's heart and Superman being like wait
wait wait Bruce you don't understand like you know
even though I've been trying to kill you I don't
want you to die yeah exactly I don't want you to
die yeah and what a great way to show the goodness
of Superman even though he's been being evil this
movie yeah like even though he's you know leading
with violence and like being a war criminal and
doing all these things it's stopping Bruce at
that last second that shows he's still Superman
yeah and and I liked you know I mean I think Frank
Miller especially often tends to put the Talking
Heads in and especially Reagan Era and Cold War
era you know tensions seem to kind of flavor the
periphery of a lot of his stories or at least the
ones that I've been exposed to most directly and
uh I like the way that that too yeah it's like it
raises these strange questions both about you know
I'm sure there's comparison to be made between
like the methods of a Batman type character
versus the methods of this of of you know the
American government in situation and who's
better the one that's listening to his own rules
or someone that's just following orders someone
that listen to the government's rules yeah that's
the that's the question yeah and having Superman
in that position where he's like it's their Planet
they're the author of my orders and I thought that
was like even though it's just a small beat of the
the sequence and the conversation I'm still like
that is an interesting you know place for Superman
to be coming from and Batman be the only one that
solved the like Gotham being safer than the rest
of the country because of the vigilanteism because
of those things juxtaposing their embarrassment
yeah fighting away and I thought that was really
cool too finding a way to to flip that around and
because at the at the end of the first one you're
like oh the sun's a Batman like this is this
is getting out of hand like these people are
all Gonna Take The Wrong message from this and
it's only gonna make things worse and then yeah
it comes down to like well I've got these people
at my display as much as I yeah there's that whole
you know threat about like I didn't I didn't
choose these guys like these are you know my
my team my picks but hey they're the ones they're
willing and so if they'll listen you know I will
lead them so in an hour and 15 minutes that movie
had Bruno First Act Joker second act Superman
third act that movie introduced Selena Kyle that
movie gave us all those street level fights and
then the big fight that movie gave us the you know
the iconic now iconic to Todd Phillips with the
iconic talk show scene sure it did a lot in an
hour and 15 minutes it did and it didn't feel it
felt long again it felt long ago in a good way
yeah and it didn't feel like it rushed those
iconic moments no no and and yeah just again the
way they've the way they have realized the Frank
Miller art with some of the you know exotic images
yeah yeah and I feel like you know it's kind of
it's not like a 100 only his art Style translation
but I feel like the way they have adapted his art
style with you know the current to this you know
Moment In Time 2012 or whatever it was art style
was really lovely the way they pull certain panels
was really nice keeping in the spirit of all the
Frank Miller design work I'm so impressed that
Frank Miller loves his character stoic yeah and
I'm so impressed with how stoic everyone was to
be accurate to the story about how we still cared
sure like we cared when Gordon's house blew up
and like we've met Gordon very briefly he's always
like everyone's got like that like I'm gonna be
stiff-faced and yet everyone you're still invested
in you see Mrs Gordon like one time yeah and
you're like oh my god oh yeah and when she shows
up you're like thank God and that's like we don't
get many interactions with any of these characters
and it's really impressive yeah Selena getting mad
at Clark like those moments like it's very very
brief to get there but they use the time well yeah
and even Robin like you know you don't do you get
the most personal look you just get like one scene
in the previous installment of like what her life
is like but even here like brought so much like
pluck and heart without it feeling out of place or
without it feeling hammy or or I don't know just
like it managed to incorporate that character in
such a lovely fun way you know for a splash of
brightness but it still felt like perfectly in
line with everything yeah like I yeah I just love
the relationship between the two of them the way
they drew like the triangle of like her him and
Alfred and uh freaking Oliver Queen showing up I
forgot all about that arm ripped off like taking
pieces of him and he just wants a piece back oh
that was so good yeah yeah I don't think I've
read Frank Miller's Dark Knight Returns since
97 98 I was gonna say that was a long time I
read it because it was like I'm getting into
comics and I'm looking outside of just the
ones I know like I remember it being I read
you know Spider-Man and X-Men is what I always
bought growing up it's what I always collected
but then I think I was like eight or nine and I
was like I should see about the big ones and I'd
ask like people that are like me now like I'd ask
people at comic stores and stuff like what should
I read and I remember Dark Knight Returns is one
of the first ones I read to be like I read Comics
not just Spider-Man and X-Men I haven't read that
in like 20 plus years yeah but it was cool to go
back yeah absolutely like it I I feel like this
was one of those ones that I would have checked
out of the library when I was yeah like the early
2000s yeah when I was starting to kind of get into
these things and uh uh yeah like I I'm excited
to like watch this again and even maybe watch
the full just like one it was cool to see in
pieces and it'll be cool I'm gonna give it a
couple years and then watch it what I'll probably
do is I give a couple years read it and then watch
it all as well that's a good idea like experience
it in the multimedium yeah because I haven't even
rewatched Guardians 3 yet I've been so busy I
want to watch I want to watch Guardians one two
and then three and I think it'll be fun to do this
with read returns then watch oh yeah I just want
to have a set right behind you I just wanna have
a real someone I have a nihilistic day sometimes
you need it yeah and I mean too these are like
you know again not everybody agrees with uh Frank
Miller's of perspective and he has a strong
one yeah so inherently that's gonna cost yeah
yeah but I do appreciate that in these Landscapes
because it also is it makes it more striking it's
like okay there's there is definitely you know
a level of political commentary going on in your
first time experiencing this movie like there's
so many different things to appreciate that you
know I'm excited to go back and be like okay what
is this actually also saying as a Batman piece was
it saying about Batman what's it saying about
society and it's great to adapt loyally but but
have the flexibility to make a Frank Miller Thing
feel so authentic but the medium allows for it and
I I was saying to you before I always say that you
need to adapt to not translate this is as close
to translating I think works like this is damn
near translation there are obviously things that
are flexible but like this really worked as a mere
translation yeah yeah absolutely and uh too I just
like the the uncomfortableness of you know it's
like I think Batman is one of those characters
where it's people debate the philosophy and and
you know whether he's killing people or using
guns and I do like that this kind of Teeters on
that line of like yeah he's got to do a bunch of
ugly stuff and some of this certainly does not
morally you know jive with everything and that's
just part of the mess yeah it is a mess to be
a person's best to be Batman yeah and there's
no kind of like 100 just morally excusable version
of this uh and so yeah it's it like yeah there are
a lot of people who have died at Batman's hands
yeah certainly and you know you still have that
moment of like these are these are clumsy these
are the tools of cowards yeah and and I believe
that message even despite the the you know just a
mess of of what it means and is to be Batman and
the fact that yeah like there is a sort of moral
question that is not going to come to a succinct
answer like I said it's it's Frank Miller's got a
strong opinion so whether you're worth it or not
at least you can see the take which I like yeah
yeah and this has that thing of it I mean you
know it does have that thing of like you know
you're you're that that sentiment Zack Snyder
record of like yeah you're superhero characters
are in a realistic world aren't going to be
these Saint figures yeah and I like the way that
that is communicated through something like this
because you can have your fun but you can also
look at it and kind of pick it apart that way
and I think Superman is another good example of
that phenomenon I agree and uh because obviously
you know you look at Superman is such a Beacon of
Hope and freedom and truth justice America we're
taking out all these like uh airplane carriers
yeah he's just also boy just like you know going
out there fighting the KGB and stuff like that
you know messy and uh and so you yeah like it is
a a bit of a man and like he he cradles uh what
is her actual name uh uh Robin Robin in his arms
and calls her Soldier yeah and Soldier good
soldier yeah and so like there's those little
just pepperings of the fact that this is all
kind of tragic yeah but also you know living
in a tank and you get the plane and yeah all
the moments yeah there's like so much cool
[__] too I wonder what is next our our end
of dcau yeah are we doing the war or whatever
um a question because they have like a couple
more before the end because the the comments
we're saying that we were like right at the end
of that Universe which is crazy the end is nigh
I believe it is uh it's coming because we
just did uh we did what was the last one
super rain of the Supermen yeah and so then
we have hush and then we have Wonder Woman
Bloodlines and then there's apocalypse War so
yeah there's three left in the AMU continuity
we're working on and then if we decide to
jump into some red Sun yeah tomorrow verse
we've only got three amu's left that's crazy I
know right yeah and I mean it's it's almost two
it's like I I like going through the continuity
but I also really appreciate when we're taking
a little side steps take a side step out of
continuity into something else that's isolated
like this then we've got some new ones yeah so
this can be fun uh let us know in the comments
what of these you're excited to see us see not
sure which one we're doing next in release or
watch but one of them soon and we're approaching
the present and then we'll also go back and forth
through time like we did here to 29th third I
think it's 2013 yeah so we'll play around there
so that is going to do it for I was like we did
we rap no we didn't we said we're about to rap you
know what we need one one slash point before we
go okay what do you got more bat horse more media
we should do Batman my gas gas slam yeah Batman
in The Gaslight District Batman goes to San Diego
Comic-Con and looks for a place to eat during
Saturday rush hour that is its own adventure and
it doesn't end well for Batman or the bat toilet
uh that said I think it's Batman I think it is
either way I know there's a video by some kind
of games I tell you the Joker that joker gas got
nothing on Batman after a burrito tell you what
that's why it goes through so many Robins anywhere
as a cape there's a lot of reasons about this
there was so many horrible so much makes sense oh
man oh man you thought the ventriloquist Batman's
Ass toxin the thrillicus would talk himself before
Batman farted around now he's got to talk to
a doll Lynn messed him up so bad that's why I
have a two-face he got hit straight with a with
a gas bomb from Batman ripped half his face off
a lot it's a whole lot so much so much anyway
I don't know how to uh we gotta wrap this up
before before I let this keep going in Batman
goes to Chipotle thank you for being here thank
you for thinking of our patrons thank you for
espousing the good word of comic books let us
know what you want us to watch likes you need to
comment what you thought of Frank Miller's Dark
Knight Returns part one and two and um what do
you think Frank Miller listens to when he draws
we had to talk about talking Patron so uh let us
know what you think Frank Miller's Vibes are all
right much love we'll see you soon rejection uh
before we go let's do a patron of the day Shout
and our patron of the day is gonna be Garth
Mick Murray who is always espousing the glory
of comics and the glory of good storytelling
and the glory of Superman and a glorious comic
store uh I believe is called Kamikaze which
is in Davis Square in good old Somerville
just outside of Boston kid uh I have not yet
attended but I vowed the next time I went to
Boston I would and so I will so we're gonna give
some love to Garth McMurray and his beloved comic
store I love how much this man loves this store
I love how dedicated he is to it so not only is
he a loyal Patron not only is he a man of
good taste but he is a man of local comic
book shops which I respect and appreciate
so much love to carthink Murray much love
to Kamikaze and much love too I'm sure they have
some Frank Miller books in there they have some
some sweet sweet stuff so I want to make sure
we have some comic specific love to one of the
titans of comics Frank Miller so thank you to
Garth McMurray for speaking the good word of
comic books and for being a glorious Patron
we appreciate you [Music] foreign [Applause]